[Music]
on this tuesday night
the rise in racist attacks against
asians
be a good human being we need love and
kindness
the amplified voices demanding
government action
a deadly rampage inside a colorado
grocery store
let's just run get out of there tell
everybody to leave the survivors
and the victims new scrutiny of oxford
astrazeneca's vaccine
the accusations of cherry-picking data
and when flu season doesn't go viral
influenza is actually at a historic
low a plus side to all those pandemic
precautions
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
we have a hate problem in this country
and it's getting worse over the course
of the pandemic
a new report has documented more than a
thousand racist
incidents targeting people of asian
descent over the last year
from people being spat on to more
physical acts of aggression
and these are just self-reported
incidents the scope of the problem is
likely bigger
travis dunroj has our top story tonight
it is disturbing to watch but also
conveys a powerful message
this calgary woman skateboarding a man
on a bike passing by
spits on her hurling a racial slur a 92
year old asian man with dementia grabbed
and thrown out of this vancouver
convenience store
slamming his head on the pavement
incidents across the country fueled by
fear over the pandemic
avigo has personal experience this
summer a group of young people spat on
the toronto lawyer when she was out for
a walk
these races target seniors young people
as well as people who may not speak
english as their first language
so we're talking about more vulnerable
population within our society being the
targets
a new report from the chinese canadian
national council echoes that
it breaks down 643 complaints received
from march to december last
year and what it details is disturbing
verbal harassment accounts for about 73
percent of the incidents
nearly 11 percent involve some sort of
unwanted physical
contact aggression or physical force
almost 10 percent
are related to the shunning of asian
canadians
and another 10 percent involve spitting
or coughing on asians
so survivors of you know racist attacks
should have counseling support
individual-based support community-based
support that's linguistically accessible
and culturally relevant the report also
found about 60 percent of the incidents
were directed toward women
canada's top doctor teresa tam has also
faced
race-based social media vitriol
absolutely we
should not tolerate um hate
or racism against any
groups in our community still asian
canadians are standing tall
fighting back denouncing hate
in montreal hundreds rallied this
weekend after the murders of six asian
women in atlanta georgia
give us a break enough is enough stop
hurting one another
on the streets in toronto's chinatown
optimism a vaccine
an end to covet will also help subdue
the spread of fear
and discrimination hopefully you know
we'll be able to go beyond that and
and everyone will be able to get along
you know hopefully the world will come
back to normal
travis stanrash global news toronto
the u.s is reckoning with its own racism
directed at asian americans
the organization stop aapi hate
documented nearly 3 800 incidents
between march 2020 to the end of last
month
the majority 68 was verbal harassment
11 percent involved physical assaults
last week shootings
at three atlanta area massage parlors
have further fueled fears
about violence against people in the
asian community
of the eight victims six were women of
asian descent
ten people including a police officer
are dead after an attack at a colorado
grocery store
it's the second mass shooting in the u.s
in less than a week
today boulder police chief maris harold
fought back tears as she read the
victims names
one by one denny strong
20 years old nevin stedinsky
23 ricky odds
trellona barcanovic 49
suzanne fountain 59.
terry liker 51 officer
eric talley 51. kevin mahoney
61. lynn murray 62
jody waters 65.
the 21 year old suspect faces 10 counts
of first-degree murder and as jackson
proska reports
police still don't have a motive
gunshots rang through the supermarket
monday afternoon
as a single shooter turned his sights on
shoppers and store employees
somebody had their hand on my back i had
my hand on somebody's back
and we were just saying go go go run the
first police officer on the scene
51-year-old
eric talley was killed an 11-year
veteran of the boulder police
talley's cruiser now sits as a memorial
outside the local police department
you know it's tragic this officer had
seven children
ages five to 18. in this small city the
shooting hits close to home for almost
everyone
the people who were killed yesterday
were individuals
going about their daily business when a
man with a gun
monstrously struck them down the alleged
gunman is a 21-year-old man who was shot
through the leg before his arrest
he's been charged with 10 counts of
first degree murder
investigators believe he bought the
rifle used in the attack
just six days ago the unfairness of it
all
is going to be difficult for people to
process colorado has become synonymous
with gun tragedies
columbine aurora and now boulder
this is the second mass shooting of this
scale in just the last week in the u.s
in washington president joe biden made
an appeal for congress to restore the
assault weapons ban
and close loopholes in background checks
immediately
this is an american issue it will save
lives
american lives and we have to act but
lawmakers have so far
been unwilling to act blocked by
republicans who've rejected even modest
gun controls
all but ensuring no end to the uniquely
american cycle of mass shootings
at the hands of lone gunmen jackson
prosko global news
washington the defense minister
and acting head of the canadian armed
forces were both in the hot seat today
a second parliamentary committee has
begun investigating the treatment of
women in the military
the meeting follows high-profile
allegations against senior members of
the forces
first brought to light by global news as
abigail beeman reports officials say
efforts are underway to address sexual
misconduct
in the ranks we will eliminate the toxic
culture of toxic masculinity that still
exists the defense minister offered big
promises but few answers as he was
grilled by opposition mps
you're still not owning up to this
then how do you expect the culture to
shift
military police are currently
investigating both former chief of the
defense staff jonathan vance
and his replacement admiral art mcdonald
two parliamentary committees are also
digging
in the status of women committee
focusing on the culture and treatment of
women in uniform
some of the gaps are becoming apparent
such as
power dynamics and understanding the use
of
an abuse of power in a a hierarchy like
our own
the new acting cds says military members
get annual sexual misconduct training
though he thinks once a year is not
enough lieutenant general wayne ayer is
promising a new code of conduct and
boosting a support program with a single
point of contact
we are offering that from a centralized
location but we are currently looking at
expanding that to have
regional sites across the country but
this week
marks six years since a landmark report
pointed to the
endemic nature of sexual misconduct
within the forces
can you talk about implementing the rest
of the day sean report your plans for
that specifically
our plans are very immature at this
point
but what we need to do is a stock taking
a stock taking
six years after those recommendations
were made
the committee also heard the defense
minister repeat an independent
complaints reporting structure is in the
works
but no details about what it will look
like or when it will be ready
abigail beeman global news ottawa
and late today the military ended its
review into allegations a member of the
navy
made inappropriate sexualized comments
that referenced a scene from 50 shades
of grey during a meeting in january
the investigator concluded there was no
service offense and closed the case
china is lashing out against canada and
other western nations over
sanctions for human rights violations
beijing has countered with its own
sanctions
and is threatening further action as
michael couture reports
political experts believe it's a sign
international pressure
is working a day after canada the u.s
u.k and european union hit china with
coordinated sanctions for its treatment
of uyghurs
the chinese foreign ministry struck back
with a strong statement
these countries have claimed to be
judges of human rights and acted as
lecturers of human rights says the
spokesperson a statement from the
chinese embassy in ottawa even
singled out canada saying it is in no
position to act as a teacher on human
rights issues
china also announced retaliatory
sanctions against 10 people in the
european union
and then ramped up the rhetoric against
the coalition
of western countries they will
eventually pay the price for their
foolishness and arrogance
she said there's an edge to it that i
haven't seen
for some time in terms of the precise
language being used a lot of references
to the past
denigrating the importance of the north
america and europe as compared to
the rest of the world i think they're
caught between a rock and a hard place
here
former diplomat charles burton believes
china is getting very defensive and it's
a sign the coordinated international
pressure
is working getting china to understand
that
everybody's interests are better served
by
playing by the rules including not using
hostage diplomacy which many believe is
what led to the detention and trials
of michael kovrig and michael spavor our
ambassador dominic barton wasn't in
china for the court proceedings
he's back here in canada for high-level
talks
it's best to have an ambassador there
but i think it also is sending a signal
of dissatisfaction which is fully
warranted in my view
so far china has not announced any
retaliatory sanctions against canadians
but it's widely believed
that will eventually happen mike
lacrouter global news ottawa
now to the fight against kova 19 we have
good news and bad news
first the good news vaccinations are
ramping up as of tonight more than 3.5
million canadians have received at least
one dose
that's about 9.3 percent of the
population
now here's the bad news with new
variants in the mix and many canadians
still not protected
case numbers are climbing over the last
week the number of cases confirmed per
day in canada
jumped by 15 percent some provinces are
reporting a growing number of younger
canadians getting
very sick we have seen
several young people in their 30s and
40s who've unfortunately tragically
been severely affected by covet as we
are protecting more and more
older people we're also seeing risk in
younger people and younger people are
ending up in the icu
and needing icu care for a longer period
astrazeneca is facing more turmoil over
its coven-19 vaccine
just hours after the company released
extremely positive results from its u.s
trial american health officials cast
doubt on the data used
they say astrazeneca may have included
outdated information
which may have given an incomplete view
of the results yesterday the company
released data showing the vaccine was 79
percent effective at preventing
symptomatic cova-19 but u.s officials
reportedly sent astrazeneca a letter
suggesting
they overstated the results they say
more recent data shows the range may be
69 to 74 percent effective
astrazeneca says it will release more
up-to-date results within 48 hours
health canada says it will monitor that
data but the concerns in the u.s
do not change its position that oxford
astrazeneca
is safe and effective based on the
findings that we've seen
and even if there are some differences
in terms of the final data points
really that the bottom line is that it
doesn't change the recommendations at
this point in time we
of course believe that the benefits of
the astrozenica vaccine continue to
outweigh the risks
canada has already received 500 000
doses of the astrazeneca shot from the
serum institute in
india another 1.5 million doses are
expected from the u.s
in the next couple of weeks canada's
oxford astrazeneca vaccines will soon
contain
a new warning label health canada says
it's following europe
and adding a warning about the potential
risk of extremely rare
blood clots the european medicines
agency completed a review last week
after a very small number of reports of
rare clotting
in people who were vaccinated the agency
says the shot is safe
but it could not rule out a link the nhl
is postponing more of montreal's games
over covet 19 fears until at least
sunday
two of the canadians are on the league's
protocol list meaning they either have
the coronavirus
or they may have been exposed to it
their test results are expected this
week
the league hopes the canadians can start
practicing again on monday
the anaheim ducks also canceled today's
practice because a player is being
tested
for the virus the conservatives and
climate change coming up the polarizing
topic that's igniting a fierce debate
within the party
conservative leader aaron o'toole is
struggling to unite his party on what
could be a make or break issue in the
next election
a majority of the party's grassroots
voted against his proposal to officially
declare that climate change
is real opposition parties are quick to
pounce on the divide
let's bring in our chief political
correspondent david aiken david how does
aaron otule move forward on an issue
that is top of mind for so many voters
it might seem obvious to point this out
robin but conservatives have to win over
voters who right now are telling
pollsters
that they would not vote conservatives
and one of the reasons that they're not
voting conservative
is because of the party's climate change
policy even the conservative leader
said as much climate change is an
important subject that canadians want to
see that we have a serious plan
on we will have that but the slim
majority
vote by the party's grassroots to reject
a climate change declaration
will hobble o'toole's attempts to do
that it is a test of being coherent
and that might prove a challenge for the
conservatives i think certainly makes a
difference to voters i think
all canadians agree that we are up
against a crisis
and that we need to do something about
it o'toole insists
his yet to be announced climate change
plan
will be a vote winner i will be focused
on an economic recovery in all regions
and in all sectors of this country
and a serious climate change plan too
stay tuned i know you'll like it for now
though the only thing o'toole has said
about his plan is that he
like every conservative leader before
him would cancel the federal carbon tax
and rebate program and
that position is hugely popular in
alberta saskatchewan and many rural
parts of canada
but to win government o'toole needs to
reach the so-called persuadable voters
in regions the conservatives have not
won in a decade from
vancouver island to urban and suburban
ontario and quebec and
right now multiple polls show that few
of the persuadable voters in those
regions are even considering switching
to the conservatives and one big reason
is a perception the party itself is not
serious
about climate change and that vote at
the party's convention
seems to prove that point robin david
aiken in ottawa thanks david
by the way the federal government will
table the 2021 budget on april 19th
it will be the first official budget in
more than two years and the first since
the liberals minority win
in 2019. the trudeau government will
need opposition support
to pass it still ahead hundreds
unaccounted for
after a deadly inferno at a refugee camp
you're watching global national
[Music]
fields of charred rubble are all that's
left after a fire swept through a
tightly packed rohingya refugee camp in
bangladesh
the death toll is at 15 but at least 400
people are still unaccounted for
and groups say barbed wire fences
surrounding the camp
made it difficult for people to escape
the un's refugee agency says as many as
45
000 refugees have been displaced the
cause of the fire is still not known
however it's believed exploding gas
canisters
fueled flames that burned for more than
10 hours
israel's prime minister is holding the
lead in the country's fourth election
in two years giving him a chance to form
a coalition government
the vote is considered a referendum on
benjamin netanyahu's rule
he is israel's longest-serving head of
government in power since 2009.
his party campaigned on the country's
successful vaccination rollout
voting boxes were even brought to
patients bedsides today
his rivals say he is unfit to lead while
fighting charges of fraud
breach of trust and bribery evanston
illinois a chicago suburb is the first
place in the united states to pay
reparations to its black residents
who have suffered decades of housing
discrimination city council passed a
plan to hand out
10 million dollars over 10 years each
eligible resident will receive
up to 25 000 to qualify applicants must
be a black resident of evanston between
1919 and 1969
or direct descendant up next the season
that never was how canada crushed cases
of the flu
down to a few
health workers are seen as the
superheroes of this pandemic and a
well-known artist's depiction of this
sentiment
has just broken a record the banksy
painting called
game changer shows a young boy playing
with a nurse action figure
instead of batman and spider-man it sold
for almost 30 million dollars canadian
setting an auction record for the
elusive british street artist
proceeds will go to supporting uk health
charities
chances are you didn't get the flu this
year there were so few cases in canada
that health officials were unable to
declare the official start
of the flu season as eric sorensen
explains it's clear
measures like wearing face masks and
physical distancing
made a big difference in a winter spent
avoiding one another a remarkable thing
happened
the seasonal flu went away every year
up to 7 million canadians normally get
the flu
this winter did you get the flu this
year no i didn't
i didn't get the flu this year and ellen
barbieri thinks it's obvious why she
didn't get sick
haven't hugged touched seen anyone
i wasn't going to the office downtown
and touching all the doors and all the
undergrounds
it seems the measures taken to hold off
covet 19
all but snuffed out influenza this past
season
laboratory confirmed detections of flu
usually total about 38 000 in a normal
flu season
this winter canadian labs confirmed just
64 cases as of early march
influenza is actually at a historic low
and if there's just not enough virus
circulating and with people social
distancing
and wearing masks it's just not
transmitting
here's the map of flu activity for the
first week of march
last year there was flu all over the
country for the same time period this
year
almost nothing last year was much more
typical
the flu season began in november 2019
and it ended in march of 2020
the flu season lasted 18 weeks about
four months long
the flu season this year it never began
all this speaks to is the fact that our
public health measures work for flu as
well
this infectious disease specialist says
it's strong evidence just how
dangerously virulent covert 19 has been
left uncontrolled this would have been
absolutely devastating to the world
the drastic reduction in flu will make
it more difficult to predict what the
next influenza threat will be
but experts say there is a lesson to
carry forward of the value of social
distancing and staying home when sick
when you bring your viruses with you to
work or to school
you're sharing those with the community
some just want to return to the way
things were
i'm looking forward to that not having
to be paranoid
but others expect to be more careful in
the future maybe just
more the elbow more conscious of the
fact that we can all do more to limit
the spread of viruses
i'll probably just be a little more
aware of my distance
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
tuesday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is downtown london
ontario
we would love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back at the anchor desk tomorrow
and i'll see you on friday have a great
[Music]
night
[Music]
you